Shelly is with us in Los Angeles hi
Shelly how are you hi there Dave hey
what's up oh not much thank you for
having me on your show it's an honor was
honored to have you how can I help
well um my boyfriend promised me that he
would take care of his fat taxes while I
went back to school full-time for a year
and I recently learned the other day
that she did not take care of that and
he now owes approximately $70,000 in
back taxes now I've graduated and I've
been working for a little over three
months and I love this man dearly and I
want to start a future with him but this
is definitely going to delay that and so
I just want to know how can we as a team
work together to you know get this off
of his plate so that we can start our
future together okay well there's two
potential problems the taxes themselves
don't bother me um how we got into this
mess in the first place is a habit
pattern that's a deal breaker if that's
not changed and then the fact he told
you is going to take care of this and
hadn't worked on it so you now care more
about it and he does that's a deal
breaker - so tell me more about those
two things how did he get into this mess
well you got into this back in the
recession so what started all this
recession does it cause you'd be behind
on taxes you make less income in the
recession that's when he chose to stop
paying his taxes I can't speak for him
but I'm assuming whenever you're looking
at it you you you know what's going on
why did he not pay his taxes well I know
that you want to self-employed and I
know he lost a lot of his clients I know
he lost his house I know that he fell
into a deep depression over this and
wasn't really didn't have any money
coming in so I would say just due to
depression and lack of responsibility
during that time frame okay um and what
I would want to know how old are you I
am 44 he's 47 if you had a daughter
okay that was getting rare
it was going to marry and this guy is a
young man comes in and sitting at your
table and he starts telling you this if
I have two daughters that are married to
two fabulous young man I would want to
be interviewing them I want to be asking
them okay when you guys as a couple hit
the wall and have struggles again is
this God is this pattern going to repeat
itself where you become debilitated by
hard times and can't work your way
through them well I I press I don't
think so I mean because of him I was
able to save up money and was able to
quit my pharmaceutical job of 13 years
and go back to school I get my second
degree
why I pray why because why because of
him I understand well he basically
carried the reins so I know that he is
responsible I mean he did an excellent
job let's say a recession hits in his
life your all's life as a married couple
falls apart again that's what I'm saying
is he going to repeat this pattern that
he went through
that's concern number one because why
not or is this the cuz I went through
hell I lost everything and that doesn't
disqualify someone from being marriage
material that's not what I'm but but but
what you don't want is if this if the
the taxes are a symptom and if the
problem that caused that is still there
you know walking into this marriage
you're facing that that's why you're
calling me right right well yeah I'm
trying to find out what's the best
solution for him to type of a therapist
taken care of because I know he for him
to deal with the root cause that's the
best solution not for you to fix it for
him and when you offered him the chance
to go fix it for himself he didn't go do
it why was that well I was going to
school full-time and she basically was
paying for everything the rent the bills
and everything during that timeframe so
but you had you had agreed that he was
going to work on the taxes and he never
did and he never brought it up again
until afterwards and he said oh yeah
yeah well I hear you yeah I'm not saying
this is a deal-breaker but the ups and
the you know life knocked me down and I
can't get back up and so I'm in a hole
and five or six years later I'm still in
that hole these are
these are the things you're going to be
dealing with you did ten years from now
they're going to have a little different
label on them or flavor
if he hasn't dealt with it now when I
you know when I went through hell I mean
Sharon Ramsey she was one seriously
terrified woman and she was scared to
death and if she couldn't recover from
that terror and 25 30 years later we're
still dealing with that with Sharon then
she you know that then we'd have that
issue right I mean if every time we got
really do something she had a meltdown
because of what happened 30 years ago
then that means she didn't heal and
didn't learn and didn't grow from the
thing we went through obviously I did a
whole lot of stupid stuff and made up a
life out of the fact that I stopped
doing all that stupid stuff and made a
brand out of that so I'm not bragging on
us I'm just saying that's a normal
progression when you go through hell is
to come out with scars but never go back
and that's what I want to make sure
happens here so I can't answer that and
I mean we've felt around the edges of
this thing and we're not really you and
him have to get into that I would
recommend some good in-depth
pre-marriage counseling for the two of
you and this needs to be center of the
plate as you're as you're serving up the
course of pre marriage counseling
how did this get here why is it still
here and not mechanically not how he
took care of you and not he told you
he's going to take care of it and he
didn't and I got behind on my taxes when
I went broke and I had to go to clean up
the dadgum KGB I mean the IRS they were
a pain in the butt so it doesn't
disqualify someone as marriage material
for that but here call me because you
got this little bell ringing in the back
of your head and that's God's Spirit
saying be cautious my daughter and so be
cautious you know don't just accept his
word and I'm not saying it's a
deal-breaker please I'm not saying this
guy's off the table but boy I'm if you
are my little sister which is what you'd
be at 44 if I'm 55 then I would put my
arm around you and say pre-marriage
counseling in depth not the high five as
you drive past the preacher I'm talking
about where you dig in and you dig out
everybody's crap and you put it on the
table and you deal with it and that
by the way that's great for anybody
that's engaged but particularly as old
dogs going through a cycle I mean
somebody going through it 44 is a lot
different than 24 but you still need to
dig into it and high correlation between
successful marriages and how much in
depth free marriage counseling they did
by the way
for all of us to know that but um yeah
that's how I would look at it so good
question good question
so let's recount that recap that as a
principle for everybody out there for
all of you listening Dave Ramsey has
never said one time in my life don't
marry someone because they have debt
I've never said that I have said don't
marry them because they love debt or
they overspend and they're immature and
the debt is the symptom of a bad
character that's telling you not to
marry them I've said that many times and
I'm not sure which this guy is I don't
know but she needs to find out doesn't
she and that's what we're digging into
all of us together it's why the show is
so stinkin popular it's real life on the
radio
it's the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you